sherry uh it's a beautiful morning all
across the nevada right now look at that
gorgeous shot oh wow that is beautiful
yeah speaking of score
mother nature is scoring this morning
with beautiful beautiful weather out
there
we've got some mid-level clouds no rain
from these clouds expected
the air's still very dry we're averaging
about 15 humidity
gorgeous sunrise and temperatures are
very comfortable in the mid to low
70s and actually that's right on target
for normal even though we were a little
above normal
this weekend upper 90s 97 saturday 99
yesterday less smoke in the air and that
looked a lot better
and smelled a lot better as well friday
was just ugh it was that brown
haze everywhere 70 degrees red rock this
morning 67 in front still some 60s up in
mesquite and over into kingman
laughlin at 80 degrees so have some
breezes up at kyle canyon but we're not
expecting too much
in the way of wind yet now they'll get
more wind
but cooler air and maybe some rain with
this low pressure
system into the pacific northwest and
just kind of a series of disturbances
so the red flag warnings have been
issued for idaho
over into montana and also in parts of
northeastern
california and southern oregon also all
those air quality alerts unfortunately
that air quality just horrible
i'm sure you've been seeing all the
pictures from all the wildfire smoke
paulette is a hurricane rolling over
bermuda the real concern
for the lower 48 states is right here
this is tropical storm sally
and it is on path to the middle of the
gulf coast states
as a hurricane a category one
by tomorrow when it's expected to make
landfall right around louisiana
99 for us today will be staying just a
little above normal and even more so as
we get into triple digits
tuesday wednesday thursday breezy winds
expected by the end of the week maybe a
few clouds
and that will bring us back to normal